the skin is the body's primary barrier
against physical insults and microbial
pathogens it represents a unique
environment in which immune cells
interact with skin cells to maintain
tissue homeostasis and induce immune
responses the skin is composed of
epidermis dermis and a subcutaneous
fatty region commensal bacteria fungi
and viruses living on the skin have
beneficial effects in the protection
against pathogens and in wound healing
the epidermis is composed of highly
specialized epithelial cells known as
keratinocytes they are continuously
replenished from just one layer of basal
keratinocytes which divide frequently
dead cells called cornea sites form the
outermost layer and are largely
responsible for the barrier function of
the skin in the dermis cells known as
fibroblasts secrete elastin and collagen
fibres that form a dense extracellular
matrix blood capillaries irrigate the
dermis while lymph fluid is drained
through lymphatic vessels to lymph nodes
specialized immune structures in which
immune cells are activated after
pathogen encounter diverse and
functionally specialized immune cells
populate the skin in the epidermis a
specialized subset of dendritic cells
called Langerhans cells sample antigen
they project dendrites upward towards
the qualified epithelial layer and
sample bacterial antigens such as toxins
Langerhans cells appear to be both
anti-inflammatory and activator ii
depending on
dendritic cells in the dermis are highly
efficient at capturing dead cells and
presenting antigen such as viruses other
intracellular pathogens or skin
associated self antigen to t-cells if
dendritic cells are the immune Sentinels
T cells are the immune effectors healthy
skin contains more than twice the number
of t-cells found in the blood most of
them are memory t-cells that have
previously encountered antigen and can
be rapidly reactivated T cells in the
epidermis are mostly cd8 t-cells a
subset that becomes cytotoxic and kill
target cells upon activation their
long-term residence in the epidermis
mostly disconnected from the circulation
T cells in the dermis are mostly helper
cd4 T cells which have a more modulatory
role in the immune response a variety of
other immune cells such as natural
killer cells
eosinophils and mast cells are present
in the dermis and might be involved in
allergic reactions in the skin dendritic
cells and keratinocytes sense tissue
damage such as wounds or cold sore
lesions that occur when latent herpes
virus reactivates and they do that
through evolutionarily conserved
receptors that recognize pathogen
derived molecular patterns or host
derived molecules that are exposed by
cell death such as DNA keratinocytes
produce antimicrobial peptides which can
kill bacteria directly inflammatory
mediators such as interleukin 1 or il-1
which activate dendritic cells and
chemokines which recruit neutrophils
macrophages and T cells activated
dendritic cells migrate to the lymph
nodes where they present antigen from
the site of infection to naive t-cells
priming them to activate and
differentiate into effector T cells
activated t-cells return to the skin and
kill infected keratinocytes to control
viral infection or secrete signals that
recruit additional immune effector cells
following viral clearance memory cd8
t-cells persist in the epidermis to
provide immunity for future encounters
with the same virus immune responses can
become dysregulated and cause skin
disorders such as psoriasis or atopic
dermatitis psoriasis is a lifelong
inflammatory skin disease characterized
by scaly reddish plaques a combination
of environmental and genetic factors
confers susceptibility to the disease
physical injury or inflammation can
trigger the formation of an acute lesion
the antigenic trigger is unknown but
current models propose that stressed
keratinocytes might release self DNA
which in complex with an antimicrobial
peptide activates dermal plasma site or
dendritic cells to secrete high amounts
of the antiviral mediator interferon
together with pro-inflammatory il-1
alpha released by stressed keratinocytes
interferon activates dermal dendritic
cells to promote T cell differentiation
the earliest recognisable change in the
affected skin is the accumulation of T
cells and dendritic cells around blood
vessels in the dermis an overt lesion
occurs when cd8 t-cells dendritic cells
and neutrophils infiltrate the epidermis
specialized subsets of T cells secrete
soluble mediators like interferon gamma
and il-17 which stimulate the
proliferation of keratinocytes and this
produces a marked thickening of the
epidermis signals from the proliferating
keratinocytes act as chemo attractants
for infiltrating neutrophils crosstalk
between immune cells keratinocytes and
dermal cells thus contributes to tissue
remodeling and amplification of this
dysregulated immune response without
treatment
acute psoriatic lesions become
chronically jhin's genetic studies have
identified psoriasis associated
susceptibility genes some of them
linking th17 cells the subset of T cells
that produce il-17 to psoriasis
pathogenesis thus immune cells in the
skin exert important roles in
maintaining the barrier function against
pathogens but can also become activated
by self antigen or harmless antigen to
cause autoimmunity or allergies